my job is director of insights is to
ensure to be insightful it's to really
study first and foremost technology
understand kind of where the technology
trends are going and begin to
directionally make sense of that second
is to think about how consumers are
going to interact with technology and
finally is to think about how this is
all going to impact our clients in a
year three years five years time and
then what I do after that is basically
if they're kind of you know study trends
which I do for a number of different
ways I process all that and I serve as
an advisor to first our team's second to
to our some of our key clients is kind
of a consultant on digital trends and
then the finally I have a big external
roll like this interview for example it
helps me build the bill the element
digital brand around the world
first of all I know I'm going to be
wrong a lot I mean and I think I allow
myself to be wrong and so but first
thing I do is I I'm tremendous avid
reader I mean I i read huge amount of
information on this topic I subscribe to
thousands of blogs I every Twitter
streams I'm read research reports I mean
read books i'm constantly reading on the
subject second thing i do is i talked to
our clients which are some of the
biggest marketers are in the world to
kind of understand what their what your
pain points are and what they're
thinking and what they're feeling and
what they're worried about and then and
beyond that I just I just talked to a
lot of folks I go to conferences I go
out and eat with technology vendors and
and through all that I mean put a
process where where things are going
one of the more pivotal trends i'm
watching i think is what we call a media
reforestation which is you know which i
think bigthink is definitely part of and
i said in a good way you know the whole
notion that you know media media over
the last five six years has been
completely democratized as you are as
your kind of your studio here and your
and your crew is proving and and with
that i think that finally that coupled
with the recession and a number of other
trends is beginning to erode you know
big media companies and and a big part
of that is the transition from from
atoms to bits so i think that all media
is going to be digital or in digital
format or in decline or tangible forms
of media will either be in decline or
gone i think in five years and includes
everything from books to dvds to
newspapers i mean they will still be
around i think some of them but i think
they'll be in decline in five years and
so at the same time there's huge
opportunities for you know entrepreneurs
like yourself or or companies to become
media to become media brands of
themselves or individuals speaking media
brands and i think there's going to just
be that's you know the economy that's
built on top of the media ecosystem is
huge you think about the advertising
agencies in that entire complex you know
you think about the pr industry is a
huge industry around media not just the
people who are employed me in the media
business and obviously as they begin to
go through changes so will so all these
industries
you